roughly I know you could used to it we  saved you and now you save others  warrior they did not save your life  they stole is she knows i order you to  terminate they created me  but they cannot control me scarlet  johansson ghost in the show I have been  watching you you don't have to remember  I saw someone down there  he wasn't human he's a known terrorist  and he's killed again  they didn't just kill them I hacked into  their minds  is everywhere and nowhere I will find  him and I will kill him you never talk  about your past that much miss fragments  there was an attack you were dying we  saved you and now you save others  everything they told you was a lie you  had a family remember that  nyeeehhh  Beauty you are  what do you want for me  they did not save your life they stole  it  how many were there before me  she was supposed to have a clean-burning  i order you to terminate  make up  they created me but they cannot control  me  you  you